[Music]
today the brand new trailer for the
action-packed adaptation of playstation
video game gem uncharted arrived online
putting tom holland once again in the
shoes of an iconic character from
popular culture and treasured by fans
around the world based on the franchise
of the same name the film is directed by
ruben fleischer of venomfame and sees
holland as conman and adventurer nathan
drake alongside seasoned globetrotter
sully played by mark wahlberg sophia ali
tarty gabrielle and antonio banderas
also star now while the world is going
nuts seeing colin's take on nathan drake
bring one major set piece from the
adventure game to life we've bravely
ventured through the trailer avoiding
booby traps and making sure to watch our
step to see what little details you
might have missed so grab a flashlight
follow our directions and see what gold
nuggets we picked up and pocketed along
the way while the essential boxes are
being checked for this big screen take
on naughty dog's franchise to match up
one thing that isn't on display in the
trailer at least is a main facial
feature on nathan's partnering crime
victor sully sullivan it might be a
minor detail to some but for fans of the
franchise it's a brave choice to make
and one that's right under his nose or
not we're referring to the infamous
moustache that sully is known for from
the uncharted game series that wahlberg
isn't brandishing here potentially
because of the time we're meeting him as
reuben fleischer's upcoming film looks
to be telling the origins of nathan and
sally's friendship there's a chance a
more youthful mentor to our hero hasn't
made the brave choice of growing some
facial hair the chances are that we will
see him make an appearance near the end
of the film though after an instagram
post in october last year from warburg
showed him brandishing a stash and
requesting that fans quote don't [ __ ]
ask as much as sully can't be seen
without keeping his top lip warm nathan
drake can't be without an all-important
trinket that he's carried in the games
since his arrival in 2007. that's
another mess with this hero is indiana
jones hat and whip this one is far less
noticeable it's also a valuable
accessory for nathan and one that binds
this new adventurer to one of history's
greatest earning a fair bit of focus in
the trailer the ring that holland's hero
is fiddling with belongs to legendary
explorer sir francis drake of whom nade
claims to be a descendant engraved with
the phrase sikh parvis magna the latin
saying is a motto sir francis lived by
greatness from small beginnings it's
also the first ever treasure that nathan
steals beating sully to the prize but
sparking off the mentor protege
relationship that looks to be replicated
here the only difference is that sully
seems to be using it as a bargaining
chip for nathan and it's for something
more valuable than treasure sam drake
nate's older brother is an essential
character that turned up later in the
game series that looks to be absent here
voicing uncharted 4 by troy baker who
also voices joel from naughty dog's
other game series set to be adapted the
last of us he's as cocky and daring at
his younger sibling so where is he in
this explosive new preview and why is he
such a hot topic of discussion the film
suggests that sam went after the same
treasure that sully is tracking down and
uses the drake family heirloom to get
nathan on board his next score sully
explains we find that gold we find him
too suggesting that this is going to be
as much of a rescue mission as an overly
expensive loot quest currently there's
no confirmation on if sam will be
turning up and if so who will play him
maybe it's another hidden treasure that
for now sony pictures has not mentioned
in the lead up to the film's release
besides the noticeably plain size homage
to uncharted 3 near the end of the new
trailer there's one enormous detail that
suggests how and why drake has found
himself in this bit of mid-flight
madness and where in the film this is
taking place along with the bog sobbing
to safety thousands of feet in the air
the trailer ends on the killer gag of
drake being pushed back outside after
being hit by a slick red sports car it
may come out of nowhere in this
particular sequence but it's one we've
already seen amongst the witty banter
between holland and warburg the trailer
also shows the big bad of the film which
looks distinctly like antonio banderas
currently unnamed on the cast list we
see him have a few choice words with our
hero at an event after shortly parking
up in the exact same car a quick
connection of the dodge suggests that
the plane drake boards is owned by
banderas as bad guy and is headed to an
exotic location for the treasure they're
after or the villain's base of
operations we're sure nathan will swap
insurance numbers when he lands to see
just how big this adventure gets you'll
be able to go uncharted when the film
arrives on february 18th 2022
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]